[Music]
[Applause]
yes
that's right
we're back baby power and fear of us
we're back
power we're back you were back from the
ethno state of Japan how is that well no
I'm back from France I went I went to
the ethno state of Japan and then I went
to France Multicultural two months yeah
then yeah two cultures that love one
another too they like they both are
fascinated with each other it's odd
um Japanese in the French yeah Japanese
people love France people like it can go
crazy I mean everybody likes Japan oh
okay
I I assumed especially Japanese people
oh well yeah they love it there Japanese
people extra love Japan why are you
talking about Japan like this it's an
ethno state is that why you didn't want
to go you're like no no no I just think
it's funny that it's an ethno State and
everybody's like a Japan [__] rules
but like they don't like they don't like
they're like the most xenophobic people
in the world I love all Japanese stuff
it is very it is very xenophobic it's
ironic because like their xenophobia is
hurting them like dramatically which is
why some politicians in Japan and the
diet are now actually trying to push for
immigration efforts because they're like
dude our country is literally like the
average age is like 87 yeah we need to
fix this I think a lot of people would
like to move there and live there if
they had the opportunity yeah and
there's so much it's ironic because it's
an island but there's so much space
actually because it's hyper condensed
Tokyo is one of the most dense cities uh
on the planet so uh you know 150 million
people live on that island like most of
them are living in uh these incredibly
dense urban areas so there are dead
towns basically like uh rural
where they do some crazy stuff they'll
show you this guy's butthole yes uh I
well I don't know why I jumped to that
goddamn
um just show his song it's quick it's
quick this guy is CR like I've only seen
tick tocks of this guy and they are did
you see that Ian
did you see that
okay because I it showed up a thumb a
preview of the frame when I dragged over
I didn't see it no but the audience
didn't see it right
well it's on YouTube what what exactly
how about could it be all right yeah
what are they gonna ban you for showing
something else on YouTube well watch
watch okay you ready Ian so wait before
we go hold on no don't start yet this
guy yeah
I've seen tick tocks of this guy he's
always like uh I want a traditional
conservative uh Hitler loving gay
I think so is this the guy is this that
I'm not sure have you seen this guy's
tick tocks
oh my God I'm about to show you his
other butthole okay ready hold on if you
if it's the same guy all right here we
go all right show me the butthole here
we go for reference this is how hairy my
butt is right now
all right so step one is
what
I've nared my body even you know how
hairy I am
are you disappointed that I'm not
shocked by this hair it's this it's just
this in four seconds of the video okay
my [__] is
worse I it's not the severity it's that
he just showed us this on YouTube in
four seconds that doesn't bother you no
it's uh education what about this wait
hold on let me show you the one now it
looks great let me show the one where he
puckers his [__]
watch his butthole
why they do that that's a bit much why
did they do that that's a bit much
that's
I couldn't I think okay so here's what
here's why I'm unfazed by this I kind of
alluded to this earlier before the
stream started but I was telling Ethan
about what I watched on our patreon
episode of my other podcast uh this this
TV show in England that they show on
channel four it's called naked
attraction so I have seen so many dicks
so many vaginas and so many buttholes
they show butthole they show everything
why would they show bubble they're like
bro a guy had a guy had a gooch piercing
oh wow and he like pulled his dick and
balls up to show his Gooch piercing and
you could and it's like basically
lacerated it's it's laser to the back of
my mind
you could see the holes of the gooch
peanut uh the the gooch piercing that
seems Dane like a dangerous place to
to be drilling holes
yeah I think so too but um uh okay naked
attraction so we've got a lot to catch
up on obviously it's been like a month
since we've sat here together
um
so let's just get right into it although
real quickly I'm gonna do this fast
there is a new collection of the sun
tell me if you want anything from here
um the flame one's easy that's a so this
is swimwear so that's fine what about
the top is it also swimwear it's swim I
mean it's the swimwear uh material
made of like the same okay but yeah we
can get you those I got the I like the
flame shorts how tall how long are they
though these they're probably pretty big
pretty long no I don't like that it's
long I want it to be short okay so then
probably those probably aren't wait let
me see the pink ones on that or the what
is that fuchsia this one oh yeah I'll
show you how it fits wait is that a swim
short or no no this is this is um
please okay I want that here this is how
it fits I want that oh that's long yeah
I want that in a large okay
it is a crazy long
that's exactly what you said it is crazy
long sometimes yeah and then this is uh
okay I want the socks and I want the
swim shorts and I want the Flames camp
shirt all right swim shorts I want in
Excel probably yeah oh what about the
green ones what is that hover over that
what's going on the green vintage button
shorts oh that's for that's for the
ladies
I'm sick and tired of this let me let me
double check it's for the ladies it's a
triple XL I can still wear it I meant
it's women's there's if there was a
triple X all in the denim I would wear
it we gotta get you in here to consult
basically like when we're making women's
we're like would you wear this yes the
answer is like almost always well what
about this one
the well I can't wear them I I don't
have another 100 yes I'm not
I'm not Barbie enough to wear wait what
there's a lot of stuff sold out already
the hell oh it's just coming soon
where does this cargo zip off pants let
me see those what's happening there
um you got some gay ones too wait where
was the cargo wait go down go down it's
pink cargo yeah these are cool actually
what do you mean ZIP off the bottom Zips
off what oh really I want yeah I want it
that's like that I want those
convertibles are those a part of them I
think it's unisex too I want those the
largest you want pink or green no I want
green okay those are fire okay cool yeah
all right I've asked for too much I'm
I'm happy well we got other stuff we've
got uh
all this stuff man it's all happening at
teddyfresh.com
thank you
nice I'm glad you liked some of that
stuff there you're so disappointed I
wasn't phased by the butthole no I've
moved on I've moved on I mean I was I
was quite surprised in the moment
because it hit me pretty hard yeah it
hit me hard man I think it's because
like everyone's been talking about it
like going crazy over it on on Twitter
and you know on the timeline so I just
I was expecting something worse but I
think because I've because of the naked
attraction show I watched last night for
like two hours I was let me see let me
go to YouTube and see if I can see a
gooch piercing Gooch piercing if you go
to tutorial Dave as long as you do this
was on YouTube
um wait wait wait don't show this Ian
I won't you got me sweating over here
with all these videos okay but look at
our plugin with the Mr Beast plugin
that's not how you spell it though oh
maybe in French
that's how everyone's spelling it I
typed Gooch like g-o-o-c-a maybe only
French people are doing this potentially
oh I I uh linked up with the the French
Mr bees or okay uh his name is squeezy
he's a really he's a really nice guy
um uh yeah him and his friends watch uh
leftovers so okay shouts out to squeezy
squeezy we're huge fans this is him only
53 Subs no France is really not popping
no no he's got 17 mil
um it's like s q u yep you came up in
Louisiana no no go back delete some of
those letters yeah it's like z i e yep
there it is oh squeezy
that's it yeah he's got 18 million Subs
why is Mr Beast in all those thumbnails
I don't know I think he's just trying to
hit the owl go hard probably why he has
like 6.7 8 million views on all of his
videos
good view shout out squeezy yeah he's
the man he's really Progressive he's
really good dude that's good all right
well let's talk about some current
events
um
current event number one Kaya and the
dogs are getting together and they're
doing much better yeah except Kaya also
broke the mirror no it wasn't her fault
it wasn't her fault seven year curse
I'm already cursed so there was a mirror
like a giant mirror that was just
leaning against the wall your fault she
brushed on it and it fell is not her
fault that thing should have been found
I waited this morning she's 46 Pounds at
four months old whoa yeah she's bigger
than I slots are oh yeah she's growing
at a rapid clip
so Ron Ronda dunzo
oh yeah Ron DeSantis is done right I
mean he's just it's like over for Ronnie
boy
sitting at 17 primary now down from mid
40s yeah the one the one thing he did
everything right then they indicted him
which they didn't but they maybe should
have I don't know
I mean I mean he's still crushing the
competition
I had not seen this bowl
swam he is eight percent what is
happening I don't know but he's about to
overtake Ron to dunzo
that's so funny I'm actually really
happy about that because we all wanted
Trump the conservatives wanted Trump
the libs wanted Trump it's going to be
so much fun Rhonda santis is like a wet
[__] towel loser dumbass yeah
Italians I love him well I've told you I
love you he's also a bit more dangerous
because like
um he likes I mean he will do he knows
the proper Protocols of like actually
passing legislation right rather than
just like yelling about it yeah he's
more dangerous because he's more
confident but he's less entertaining
which is the real problem which is good
which is great you know it's good for us
here he he's just getting done oh this
is my this ad is so stupid so Ronda
dunzo put out this ad last week and
they're getting tons of backlash
apparently
here it is 18 Ronda dunzo
wait this is copyrighted music I'm
pretty sure it's not oh yeah I tested it
open the second half of it has copyright
music I replaced it oh fantastic oh is
it still Funk though no I replaced it
with r like parody of that funk song
okay good but it still has like it's
gone
I wanna I wanna get into like the Giga
Chad mood yeah no it's it's a major Giga
chat advice okay great worries all right
so I see the problem identify the
problem he is supporting gay people
is a big problem
and want to use the bathroom you would
be fine wow this is our own man any
bathroom she choose is correct in the
future can transgender women compete in
Miss Universe yes okay pause for a
second that's my favorite part about
this like
they thought they were popping off with
this but like
remember
it was supposed to be about fairness and
you know athletic competition like
that's why we can't have trans women
compete against this woman right it's
like so what the [__] are you saying are
you saying that like trans women also
are are like inherently they have a
biological Advantage by having girl
penis that like automatically destroys
the composition of beauty pageants
right like it's just about attraction
and how attracted you are to to trans
women which there's nothing wrong with
being attractive trans woman but like
these guys are very clearly Chasers I
guess or like Rhonda says his campaign's
like sorry trans women are just they're
too hot they're too op have you seen
Hunter Schaefer are you [__] kidding
me I agree
how are you going to compete against
that
um but this isn't even really focused
solely on Trent this is just like oh you
like gay people oh yeah no it's pretty
incredibly what it is I mean this is
really an incredible uh and it's very
stupid because Trump
being like Trump is so good at reading
the room and when this was happening the
North Carolina bathroom bills were
happening yeah and Trump quite literally
was like no leave it the way it is what
the [__] are you doing no Let It Go and
people saw that and responded positively
to that because at the time there wasn't
this much fervor uh and even now the the
fervor is not like specifically about
like you know let's eviscerate gay and
trans people from existence it's more so
about more manageable elements of it
that uh that pertain to fairness or the
idea of fairness in sports so most
people are not as like uh they're not as
big zealots about you know killing trans
people as like the Matt walshers of the
world so this is a gigantic misread yeah
from the DeSantis campaign to be like
he's accepting of gay people what the
[__] oh look at this Loser yeah yeah
when like most moderates probably would
look to that and go yeah that's that's
not a bad thing it's a good thing you
know it's someone refreshing to be
honest although I guess I shouldn't be
that happy that people aren't like Pro
uh just killing all uh gay people but it
is refreshing ironically to know that
this was a flop for him
it's a major flop it's a major
miscalculation
what
he's hot he not used the American Psycho
Alpha yeah real self to Patrick Bateman
yeah no he's just like Patrick wait this
is real
yeah where did they run this on TV no no
they just put on Twitter and [__] this
this is my favorite alpha male thing
they have the American Psycho guy it's
like you understand that character right
he murdered women yeah he he killed
women not just women just everybody well
he he specifically was like I want to
kill women yeah
and so they look to him yeah
okay let me let me let me while while
this is happening I just want to
describe something to you guys okay
Patrick yes the median age
of the entire electorate in the
presidential election years
is
uh is between 39 and 40 uh 45 the median
age of Voters in those years between uh
is is like the the average the median
voter
in the United States of America is old
is older than what you would think
any average American Suburban voter that
looks at this campaign ad is going to be
like what the [__] is going on well like
like what are you signaling like some
HVAC guy in Alabama is going to look at
this and go why are there like hot dudes
uh next to rock superimposed next to
Rhonda it's pretty deep going on yeah
it's deep like internet meme Lord yeah
like no one that understands the
gigachad meme is [__] voting okay no
one we are the only people that get it
and go out and vote okay
it's so stupid this is really something
does Santa's sign's most extreme slate
of anti-trans laws of modern history
let's go yeah [__] yeah we're thinking
on this population is [__] awesome
bro you want to be you want to be
Patrick Bateman or Jay what's his name
again
you want to be Shelby
I mean listen I love
the peaky [__] blinders but again why
do you want to be a mobster murderer
this is not the comparison you want well
the peaky blinders also did not want to
be compared to the Rhonda Santos
campaign because they came out with the
state today saying that we did not
authorize uh the the usage of our
imagery in the Rhonda Santa's unofficial
campaign ad and uh you know the peaky
blinders respects the picky [__]
blinders are coming he said they we
respect old people even gay people and
also trans people as well you're making
us blinders look bad mate yeah what the
[__] you doing lad
that's what they said wait there's this
peaky blinders tweet he came out with a
well yeah you can't [__] use IPS to
promote your insane agenda on behalf of
the partners peaky blind oh you can't
read it like that
Knight Killian Murphy Karen Amanda back
Productions respect Productions
go ahead sorry no Okay Tiger aspect
Productions and Bunny J rods we
confirmed the footage of Thomas Shelby's
character used with individio posted by
Rhonda santis's campaign was obtained
without permission or official license
we do not support nor endorse the
video's narrative and strongly
disapprove of the use of the content and
I'll tell you what mate if you don't
take it that okay wait now do it I'm
trying it's not good you're doing great
you're doing great and I'll tell you
what boy
they're gonna show up at his house
a body order the [__] peaky blinders
exact your ID no don't worry Ron
DeSantis yeah it's not your ID there
don't worry they're gonna they're gonna
there's gonna be people there's gonna be
British uh foot soldiers in the chat
being like that's not a bromiac set you
[__] [__] what are you doing it's
like every accent is different in every
zip code I wish I could do one of them
yeah
what are you doing why did you post this
this is psychotic yeah he's like I'm the
sexy Giga Chad guy because what like I
am trying to kill one percent of the
population wait and then he posted a
picture of Brad Pitt from uh Troy
arguably the gayest [__] character of
all time yeah right he is very pretty
that's my favorite whenever people are
like whenever people look at ancient
Greece or like Spartans and they're like
these are men's men I'm like bro you're
right and guess what else they were
doing you know what I mean [__]
little boy that's 100 okay we're not
dabbing that up we're oh we're okay
[__] little boys oh Jesus you're just
trying to get [__] demonetized no I'm
just trying to give it up to the to the
ancient uh civilizations that they're
created democracy they literally were
tossing little kids that they didn't
want to [__] in the wolf pit okay they
were like oh this is not a [__] baby
[__] this baby yeah no they bronze like
yeah no I'm him I love him I want want
that show us child pornography Howie
Jill oh Jesus
oh this is the other thing this is the
other thing wait hold on pause it oh God
there's so much on this ad I've done so
many you have to pause and read it all
like him wait the door wait yeah [__]
nerd it's like if I'm Ron DeSantis I'm
not calling anybody a dork okay because
he is the biggest [__] dork like
like is yeah Chris Hayes wearing glasses
and they're like actually that is the
entire personification of Ronald
DeSantis okay that [__] Emoji I'd be
moving so far away from that emoji I'd
never use it I'd never want anybody to
use it because then people could
potentially say hold up it's not exactly
what Ron is like you're talking about
this guy yeah that guy
no this guy's awesome
like uh American Psycho yeah he's so
he's so hot I love those boots so he did
slay he did slay in those boots Big
sleigh he's basically Brad Pitt yeah
dude [__] Nick yeah kill yourself
nerd yeah he's like oh you want yeah you
want gay people to not be killed
freaking nerds this is crazy it's like
it's wild because oh they posted that no
they did not post that
they put that in the ad that's like he
looks like such a freak there he looks
like a alien who's never laughed in his
life oh God
oh
[Music]
so here's the other part of this right
okay here's the other part of this like
the humanist Rapport and like Chris
Hayes maybe Chris Hayes because he's
like on MSNBC sure but like the humanist
report and like then he puts Jank on
there too it's like who the [__] is this
appealing to the overwhelming majority
of American Republicans do not know who
these people are like no distract to
them they're wonderful people but like
who are you appealing to they are and
I'm on I'm like pretty active but I you
gotta love the inclusion of the
screaming sjw yeah I also love the 20
decades it's definitely a good idea to
in your political ad to put a banner
that says your candidate is evil in
giant oh yeah in your ad that's really
that's that's well dude he had a picture
of Jason Bateman walking I mean the guy
who's a match murderer yeah
I I'm telling you I think it's because
they just have lightning on there too
they're just they're just any Pace I'm
gonna make this
the governor does not care that's not
good bro
Top Gun more bait
Wolf of Wall Street prolific criminal
prolific criminal here's the problem
here's the problem the lizard person
you're not supposed to literally be like
I'm [__] the bad guy I'm like an evil
villain you're not supposed to say that
it only works when liberals say that
because you're triggering the libs and
then you're supposed to say I'm not a
bad guy but look at these [__]
pathetic liberals calling me a bad guy
even though I'm a good guy here's the
issue here Ron DeSantis and his campaign
staffers that are full filled to the
brim with like these [__] dumbass
gropers I guess or probably worse like
45 year olds who are still stuck on
4chan who think like memes got Trump
elected right those guys did not get it
those guys don't understand there is a
there's a dialectic there that they are
not they're failing to consider they're
just straight up saying haha we're
[__] evil look at how evil we are
instead of Defending yourself with a
wink and a nod against the Liberals that
are saying you're evil you can't pull
host Ron desantis's evil headline and
then also show imagery of you being like
I'm a [__] villain dog because the
moderate voter
moderate vote is not going to respond to
this anyway this is awful uh but but
even if they did see it they would have
a [__] aneurysm you know what I mean
can you imagine a woman named Deborah
who's like you know 58 years old and
lives with her [__] cats and has been
a diligent Republican voter seeing this
[__] ad
she would have an aneurysm you'd kill
Deborah congratulations it'd be looking
it'd be like looking at a new color I
don't think it would just like her mind
yeah this would not translate well no no
to the American Heartland oh he oh he
put he drew himself as a lizard person
yeah that's gonna go over great with the
Q Anon crowd wait we're gonna love it
why have you done this yeah because
she's trying to say she's an alligator
like okay I'm convinced whoever put this
together must hate Rhonda Sanchez I I do
feel sometimes that like these guys are
making such a gigantic miscalculations
they must hate him yeah he did a picture
of him as a lizard person
okay and and how does this compare
exactly he's just hot that's a hot man
that's hot man what is this what's doing
this doing for us yeah Ron DeSantis is
like a sexy tanned toned man with his
pectoris just listening in the sun this
is so we could get our nut at the end
you okay something to finish off to
what a [__] idiot what a [__]
well there you go so Rhonda Stinky's
running his own campaign into the ground
and uh we love that for him don't we
folks
unfortunately I probably means there's
not going to be a debate between stinky
and
that's a big bummer that that needs to
happen if I was drunk I would want that
to happen anyway though because like
Trump
is at his best
when he's destroying his enemies right
and I feel like putting Donald Trump on
a debate stage against Ron DeSantis is
going to
re-galvanize his positions allow him an
opportunity to come across like The
Outsider once again
because he can turn around and say look
I did everything right and they indicted
me okay I did everything right
point to like Rhonda's hands and be like
that guy is a snake that I raised from
the ground up and then the Republican
institutions used him weaponized him
against me while they turned the other
cheek as the doj the corrupt doj the
department of Injustice
put me in jail or try to put me in jail
this way
in spite of being the literal [__]
president for four goddamn years Donald
Trump could still turn around and
portray himself as an outsider it would
actually look really good for him in my
opinion if he were to go up against
little Ronda on a debate stage I would
trust me I mean [__] that'd be massive
ratings for him and I know he can't
resist that but one of my favorite
things here is there are some
conservatives who are I guess DeSantis
diehards who are desperately trying to
defend this which is incredible I Don't
Want a President Who seems eager to
divide us further and positions himself
as an enemy of any Community
I'm sorry you're a [__] Tulsi gabbard
advisor I don't give a [__] about you
you [__] loser this is the problem
Republicans Love winners or they used to
and they've actually changed a little
bit since the midterms like where they
kind of do love losers a little bit
they're behaving like Democrats
who the [__] cares about what Tulsi
gabbard's advisor has to say about
anything they're desperate dude it's
Blaze TV who else where are you gonna
find someone to defend that [__] they
had to go to the bottom so sad yeah this
guy isn't even defending it he's upset
about it that's not what the
well you'll see so a really distasteful
ad and frankly in terms of his National
Communications a very underwhelming
campaign thus far being run by Governor
DeSantis
anybody want to address that before I do
completely wrong the LGBT community is
hunting our children for grooming
purposes and dismemberment I apologize
for nothing step on the gas even harder
uh he understands uh what time it is
it's killing trans people time what time
is it bro
dude dude it's that's holy [__] dude
what are we doing American politics is
just getting juicier and juicier every
goddamn day where you got like
it is unironically the most like uh
hallucination prone person and whatever
whatever position they have that's what
the Republican party is triangulating
towards and that's really odd well it's
cool because he has Monopoly behind him
yeah which means he's a family man or
something I don't know what's going on
behind him yeah so I want to kill all
trans people and afterwards play a game
of Monopoly with my family yeah
I stands uh what time it is and there's
simply no time to be anything but
utterly honest that if you have these
people on their heels
and losing more than their winning
that's a victory
period end of sentence other than the
last sentence they are talking about the
messaging nationally was that a
criticism of DeSantis because you were
actually selling me yeah I know
yeah I thought it was the best thing
they had done yet as a campaign from a
messaging standpoint until what they
rolled out yesterday with Casey DeSantis
which is one of the best ads I've ever
seen actually holy [__] so there I mean
wow
this is of course here let me better
represent if I can uh his campaign ad
this this this is who he he he's the uh
American Psycho Jason Bateman here is um
Wolf of Wall Street [__] up on
Quaaludes
Shelby about to commit suicide
oh and then of course uh he's just
looking beautiful the thing is the thing
is though I mean here's the thing these
guys are I mean these this is fake
like this is just like a fictionalized
version of real people or just like an
outright complete fake person that never
existed right and they're like
they're trying to appeal to to Baby
brained people to be like Oh I'm just
like Thomas Shelby it's like hey guys
Ronald DeSantis here I'm just like
Thomas Shelby like okay good luck good
luck selling that to like a broader
audience you know what I mean make
yourself look cool it with with Donald
Trump
with Donald Trump at least like they
would make him look hot you know what I
mean but it was still him
like they weren't superimposing Donald
Trump next to like Thomas Shelby and
[__] this is you right now this is so
you right now it's just I I don't I
I don't know they're more oh yeah so
it's so bad it's it's so incredibly
[__] stupid to do campaign ads like
this so uh not only is the uh voter base
leaving him the Murdoch's
are starting to sour look at this guy
man I mean this guy and this is a
beautiful man right here
that's a Force for good in the world
right there he's hot
he actually owns a Vineyard near my
house
that's Murdoch right yeah yeah he owns
like an entire massive Hill and like the
most expensive real estate in the world
he bought like an entire Hill to grow
grapes on I know I
that's
due to that uh grape yard Vineyard
whatever uh I found out that he was uh
deathly afraid of covid
in his personal life look at this man in
his personal life he is uh genuinely
terrified of covet I won't reveal what
my sources are but he's right I'm just
saying he's right but like Sky News in
Australia is like you know promoting
anti-vaxxer conspiracies
doing that like interesting they've
played a gigantic role in like
brainwashing people meanwhile he's like
living on a [__]
Island carved out in the middle of Bel
Air uh so that he could like be away
from people you know what I mean if this
guy sniffed one molecule of covet he
would [__] be prepared
no this man would be in an iron lung and
it's fast that's an unfortunate reality
evil Never Dies you know so so true
let's see the conservative media king
preferred candidate to knock off Donald
Trump is not meeting expectations and
the family's paycheck is getting tired
of waiting
less than two months ago Rhonda stinky
declared his run for president and there
was lots of hype
but it's only been two months that he's
really it's hard wow he [__] that up
big time yeah because he's really bad on
camera and he's not a retail politician
at all and even in even his like
triangulation for for uh legislation has
always been like way too aggro it
doesn't
his Charisma doesn't put him
High Enough
uh uh in the in the placement for the
primaries where that matters
uh and then his legislative agenda and
the way he the the issues that he
supposedly cares about are pushes for
are toxic to the broader General uh
voter population and this is not just
the Ron DeSantis problem as I've said so
many times now this is an overarching
problem with the entire Republican party
this is a Republican party problem and
Rhonda Santos is a manifestation of that
because he is their guy he's the guy of
the Republican party people who are in
uh you know positions of power in the
Republican Party are propping him up as
the counter to Trump
um vote DeSantis guys 2024
just like Thomas Shelby
he's like Thomas Shelby vote DeSantis
that's so bad according to two sources
Murdoch has privately winced at the
santis's non-stop cultural grievance
strategy arguing that as being
executed sloppily in his repeated
attempts to outflank the already hard
right Trump on the right the Santa
sentenced team have waged an aggressive
message operation to paint the Florida
government as a much more extreme
cultural Warrior as compared with the
former president most recently via a
bizarre bigoted video louding the
governor for his anti-lgbtq attacks this
strategy has four months attracted
criticism from fellow Republicans for
being unsavvy and too online to connect
with the median voter there it is dude
I'm I'm not I could be a better campaign
consultant than like 90 of these [__]
weird lanyard wearing [__] and on
DC I swear to God I don't know what the
[__] these guys doing and I never even
leave my [__] house dude I live in
camifornia and I never leave my house
and even I have a better assessment of
like what kind of uh what is going to be
more appealing to the broader masses in
this [__] you know what this is
this is like when the Democrats with
John Kerry or with uh that Amy McGrath I
think her name was uh in Kentucky
against Mitch McConnell have always
tried to present themselves as like more
patriotic than the Republican candidate
by being like well here's a guy who
actually served it's like it doesn't
matter dude you cannot outflank Donald
Trump from the right if you're Ron
DeSantis your entire campaign your
entire messaging your entire
gubernatorial run twice has been about
how hard you ride for Donald Trump
you've utilized Donald Trump to to get a
Podium to get a platform like people are
not going to forget that number one and
number two if you recognize that
internally you recognize that you needed
Trump to win then you should also
recognize that you can't outflank him
from the [__] ride you just can't do
that what would be the best outcome is
if this just completely ruins his
political career and he just loses
re-election for governor as well that's
why I was hoping that he would debate
Trump because that that's what happened
to in the 2016 primary he like off a
bunch of political careers yeah a bunch
of ghouls I mean DeSantis is
legitimately a uh could be the next Jeb
[Music]
exclamation remember that Deb this guy
Jeff voice clap
please clap please clap this was the
best uh
uh this is the best campaign ever that's
right goat that's my goat the the
it's me Jeb a police clap yeah imagine
being George H.W bush and like being a
[__] CIA ghoul your entire life and
and promoting this like proper wasp
nationalism and and you know American
imperialism in like a different way in
the Republican Party only to have your
dumb son
who is like a [__] Yee ass Cowboy be
the president and dramatically change
the course of like American politics
forever swag though [__]
in a previous in a different world in
the George H.W bush world right like Jeb
Bush is the one Jeb Bush is the good Tom
Hanks kid to Chet hang George W bush is
the Chet Hanks of the Bush dinosaurs and
then here's the problem though if I'm
gonna watch
if I have the decision to watch
something with chat or watch something
with the boring like the guy who looks
just like Tom Hanks calling a dollar
store he's like a good actor fine but
I'm rolling with Chet that guy he I mean
there's nobody like him in the world way
more entertaining yeah the point is
Americans much prefer a Chet Hanks style
person to be their [__] president
then they prefer the Colin Hanks style
person are we suggesting that Chet Hanks
runs for president
yes yeah yeah that sounds good actually
Chad Hank's on the unity ticket yeah
since we talked about it here's just the
the Jeb Bush clip that was just so lives
in our memory the next president needs
to be a lot quieter but send a signal
that we're prepared to act in the
National Security interests of this
country to get back in the business of
creating a more peaceful world
police clap
nailed it
[__] nailed it high energy Jeb please
clap it's so bad he's the best he's the
best yeah so uh moving on let's talk
about the one aspect though the
Democrats will always defeat Republicans
on that aspect if Americans are looking
for civility Democrats are always going
to beat out the Republicans on that
front right they will always do that
unless they run a black guy in which
case no of course not because Americans
are way more racist than they care about
civility
so I want to talk about Mike Lindell the
my pillow guy who had a literal pillow
Empire this guy was worth like 200
million dollars at one point I I recall
looking up and saying and since he
became full-on conspiracy theorist for
Donald Trump simp he has lost everything
it's a really good allegory I think for
what Donald supporting Donald Trump does
to it this is [__] I did
everything he's liquidized he's
liquidating his entire [__] business
can we participate in this is what we're
here to do right now a Freightliner doc
truck six thousand dollars what this
one's three thousand oh a whole ass
[__] freight truck for three thousand
dollars [__] we shouldn't have shown
this on stream now people are gonna bid
at it [__] well he knew he listened he
needs the money so he can pay out the
guy five million dollars he owes oh my
God oh my God this is so I dude Ethan we
have to buy it we've been thinking about
it unironically there's four thousand
dollars has it
I have one weird specification can we
get a forklift does it have Mike
lindell's ass sweat on the seat I want a
signature yeah
I wanted to be used and abused by Mike
Lindell potentially yes potentially yes
um there's some really incredible things
here 500 bucks for that pallet jacks
700. those unironically you could use
down and Teddy fresh some of these I
don't know what they do but it looks
expensive air compressor air compressor
a thousand fifteen hundred I mean sure
I mean why not at that price
there's an air tank I might get some
stuff for my brother uh for his uh for
his garage well my garage that he abuses
it's just kind of far so the pack the
shipping might be get you yeah but this
is desperate times he's selling a filter
for fifty dollars
this is everything but like get to the
good [__] you know what I mean because I
this is all like industrial stuff that
people definitely need but what I want
to see is like you know like a big
Michael Pillow sign or something well
here's this I don't know what this is
but it looks very it looks like a CNC
machine seven dollars it's first it's
going currently for six dollars wait
what is this it looks very expensive
doesn't it it does look like a CNC
machine but I don't know something like
that well it can be yours for six bucks
though
that seems like a good deal I don't know
what the [__] it's a case erector I
don't know what that means automatic
case erector
we have more images guys
let's get some other angles going
I need to know if I want need this
automatic uh Case Case Maker okay man
that thing is huge five bucks let's go
right now
we could scrap that thing
automatic case erector got a touch touch
screen nice
yeah so I mean you could a lot of this
stuff will probably be stripped for
parts I assume like you could probably
sell there's other parts different
components of it for cheaper than it
I mean make more money off of it
these are all five bucks like love Shaw
Little David what is five dollars that
looks like well no one's bid on it yet
because probably because it's too big
that's the problem but I oh yeah for
sure but I'm just saying this does look
like trash though
oh it's an automated here it's like a
box maker yeah yeah it makes boxes the
case the case erector he's selling
everything you're like wow dude this
Trump ruined your life brother just get
just start smoking crack again and take
the edge off
it really does
i've smoked crap I I I stand by my
statement
that he was better on crack
absolutely he wasn't trying to ruin the
country but well this is his brain on
Jesus he went from one direction
oh my God there's got to be so many flat
boxes look at that that sucks 500 I mean
[__] dude no you should buy this [__]
Petty fresh dude that's what I'm saying
I'm seeing if what where's the value no
I want to help Mike out to a gift for
ELA just hey I got you fresh minted uh
my pill Michael Pillow boxes
look at this Canon Pro massive
industrial color printer I looked it up
that that thing sells new for over 10
grand yeah these things are cool I mean
this is just remember the bids started
and when does it close oh it's been open
for several days dude no okay well you
[__] up then yeah we're juicing it
right now well it's funny I don't care
you should have bought it it's got five
oh it's still good I'm not shipping that
[__]
there's gonna be there's gonna be people
in your in your audience that are like
oh dude this is this is exactly what I
needed good I want to hook them up if
there's I want you guys to get good
deals right now
[__] the pillows being on sale like he
usually says the whole Warehouse is on
sale today 90 off
yeah this man is selling everything
sewing machine get to see look at all
the single thing that's like Michael
Pillow related though which is kind of
sad
yeah I don't think either he may not
have touched any of these off no I want
like a like a sign that's only one page
yeah dude there's 18 pages of it oh he's
selling everything he's selling
everything so is there a way to search
because I want to see like like a
commercial grade like Pages mic pillow
do you want me to sort by uh price or
you just want his face on something yeah
yeah or like a big thing that says like
my pillow like that photo you have the
informational lot photo right there I
want that as like a massive sign or
something like he might be selling so
let me type Mike Lindell and maybe see
if anything comes up under his name Mike
lindette uh blend out like that they
spell his last name right yeah okay
let's let's see
so do we have any Mike Lindell branded
items in this 800
and 50 no
no maybe maybe just Mike look up
billboard no right billboard okay
billboard
let's see I'm like a thing I'm rapidly
scrubbing through Page by Page how about
just my pillow brand yo a bunch of
foiling cabinets I wonder a bunch of
brand internal documents Euro brand
yeah [__] man
I wish we could there's got to be
something funny in there I don't think
that there's good enough SEO I don't
think they I think there's probably
stuff there because like right truck
let's see if it comes up you know what I
mean as a test
truck yeah I don't know if they
oh come on oh and we do they're [__]
look at this bro they're selling dollies
for twelve dollars this is desperate
time holy [__] yeah I mean it's it's a
[__] full-blown
garage sale fire sale something is Dolly
desperate times calls for Desperate
Measures
I think it's time to give garyvee a call
right now get him get him right there
and just [__] eviscerate Michael
Pillow he's like this dolly
ear and a half for it and then I'm gonna
sell it on eBay for ten dollars
different perspectives I'm so sorry I
you know I I do feel bad for him he's
losing everything I cherished forklift
[__] him yeah he's lose to everything
man yeah I don't I don't feel bad for
him at all let's see sorted by highest
bid I'm just curious like what's popping
here let's see didn't I hear from
several of you that his pillows suck
like they're not good I tried it before
I knew anything about him like a decade
ago I bought it I was like because I was
looking for a new pillow yeah it was
[__] horrible yeah it's very it's
very not soft I don't understand that
why he's successful well because his
pillows were dog [__] so he had to
tailor it to like a conservative
audience you know what I mean each
pillow that you buy brother is when I'm
giving Donald Trump money when I bought
it he wasn't even doing that it was just
like buy my pillow buy my pill my pillow
is the best pillow you will have the
best night of sleep in your life whoa
look at the Discord
there's some really interesting things
that they've found in there let's see
like for example look at the last no no
no no well no not this one memory foam
curved pillows those are those are just
you know those are great those are
useful but look at the last oh the last
one this is oh this is a scandal this is
this is scary it's a scandalous I don't
know how to feel about the face masks
what it yo what the [__]
wait a whole first of all before we get
into the fact that this guy is part of
the big fraud yeah of covid but yeah but
let's talk about a palette face mask for
five dollars yeah I mean well no one's
gonna buy that Ethan why would they I
should because you don't need it because
it's China virus is is fake
why are you supporting this Mike Lindell
this is why you went out of business
yeah dumb ass loser woke as [__] dude
oh my God there's so many pallets of
face masks no there's Mike why do you
have so many face masks oh because I
have an answer look at all these Ethan
it's because I didn't use them exactly
right that's why I have so many pallets
of face masks the government made me buy
them but I refuse to use them
uh instead we started we started shaving
them down and putting him in our pillows
using it for stuffing they make a
fantastic stuffing
there's a feeling a shitload of portable
massage tables here is a Mike Lindell
and garyvee
garyvee in a passionate makeout session
with his dad after destroying the Mike
Lindell garage sale
um just [__] owning him so hard he
bought everything for eight dollars and
he's selling everything on eBay for 10.
well it's really a it's an American uh
Cinderella Story isn't it it really is
he was worth over a hundred million
dollars uh and then let's see
first he's being forced to pay 5 million
to the guy
he said if you can prove that the
election wasn't stolen I'll give you
five million someone he did prove that
and the judge actually is forcing Mike
to pay him Ethan there's there's a thing
that you can buy
yeah here click on the Discord the last
photo
okay this is oh that'd be great for you
Ethan
it's a okay it's a stool it's a stepping
it's a step school yeah
this way you can finally read that this
way you can finally be five ten stand up
okay my ribs are broken
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah Ethan is wearing platforms right
now so they're Crocs what are you
talking about
you gotta have them ribs gotta have them
ribs
when we both stood oh oh no the guys the
filter is broken I have a small torso my
legs are very long the the Ethan filter
is broken again guys yeah I'm sorry yeah
I want his true size I really need this
step stool it's pretty funny though when
we both stood up I I do look I think
they do make me much smaller no they
don't we try and make it seem somewhat
plausible size difference between you
two we were standing right next to each
other what are you talking about it's
the same frame bro oh those stools are
sick the Ford stools all right so uh
Lindell has uh revealed the company has
seen a significant plummet in Revenue
uh since he's become a full-blown
conspiracy theorist Walmart Bed Bath and
Beyond Slumberland
they've all stopped selling my pillow
products surprise who's surprised by
that
um and basically he says it's a massive
massive cancellation we lost a hundred
million from attacks by the box stores
The Shopping Network attacks and the
shopping channels all of them did they
did cancel culture on us I love that
they did cancel culture I mean I that's
such a cool way to describe just like
you know filing chapter 11 bankruptcy
they did a cancel culture I mean nobody
wants to buy my dog [__] pillows anymore
it's cancel culture do they have any
chairs for Dan
yeah they have a lot of chairs oh for
real so Dan you might want to keep your
eyes open for some now exactly
okay we'll keep it zero dollars keep it
in mind this is just coming well I can't
say no to deal like that they got a
rocker gaming chair what's happening was
Michael Lindell sitting on the gamer
chair why are they selling aluminum
wands no you have to be this is off of
Mike's listing is it not you just found
this in like the general list I clicked
the link let me try again because I
agree that looks a little there are
there are chairs uh because I was
scrubbing through all of his listing but
here look here's his here's his link
okay oh
I just want to do mics oh no yeah when
you click on that no no when you click
on that you're expanding search to all
auctions right but I haven't this is
just mine yeah it was Mike selling the
gaming chair okay okay this is all Mikey
boy
Dan
Mike L Lindell they have a lot of
computers that they factory reset I bet
you something's on one of those someone
else this might have Mike Lindell ass
smell on it the sun you might be able to
get a whiff off this oh yeah that's
that's I want to put that in a crack
pipe and smoke it you probably would get
high as sweat he previously sweats crack
bro yeah
these are some of the most deformed
ugliest okay
I love this and then what was some you
mentioned maybe something else that was
interesting I was just saying they have
a bunch of computers for sale computers
I don't know I don't know if you want
that I feel like yeah because when the
FBI is Gonna Come crashing down when
they find out a hard drive you know what
I mean exactly
wasn't me officer
yeah
oh wow this is cheap guys this is really
cheap stuff here
there it is Mike we wish you well good
luck all the best buddy
all the best to you
sorry about the cancel culture they did
on you that sucks
so
only the best for our friend there's
picture frames what the [__] is this
these are picture frames of people's
logistic Arts okay
decorations for the office I like that
it's beautiful five zero dollars in most
cases beautiful
so uh Moving On Let's see we have um the
big story that the conservatives are
hitting on pretty hard here
is they found Coke in the White House
cocaine oh my God I never heard of it
I find this story pretty uh funny for
one I mean at any given moment there's
at least 10 people doing lines in the
White House
yeah
also Joe Brandon doesn't do Coke he does
adrenochrome which is baby uh fetus
spinal fluid yeah they have to be uh
tortured first though in order to
harvest it properly well here let me
this is um Jim cavazoo it gets caught
this is the sword that they've been
obsessed with all week this is Jesse
Waters the guy who's replaced tuck yeah
it's you know the irony is not lost I
mean that it's [__] Jesse Waters
being like I can't believe they're doing
coke it's like dude you look at yourself
like what do you mean you're the one
who's gonna complain about cocaine of
the White House he's just mad that he
wasn't invited to the coke party well
listen if Joe Biden did cocaine his
heart would stop beating immediately
there's no shot he would say no I feel
like I'm a firm believer that these guys
get like obviously heavily medicated uh
but I assume it's like a much safer
cocktail of like different kinds of
amphetamines you think he's on some kind
of speed I think they probably give him
I mean they they probably think so I
think they definitely yeah speech after
8 PM they definitely ain't juice
means though I mean not like meth like a
lower level uh it was probably not like
Adderall but probably something lower
yeah like like I don't know that has
like a heavy come down I feel like he'd
be like just in such a horrible state of
being if he was on that kind of stuff at
that age
but who knows maybe sometimes I don't
know maybe
um but also then the other thing is oh
Hunter Biden was doing coke in the white
house it's like yeah dude
he smokes crack like we know that who
cares it's interesting let's see what he
says with cocaine it's usually a slam
dunk case this is a day three yeah
right cocaine gate thank God they're
talking about this and actually just to
be clear it was found in the general
area
of the White House of which how many
people work in the White House hundreds
it's not just work visitors no visitors
as well how many people go through the
White House per day hundreds easily
maybe more yeah it's uh it's [__]
awesome yeah that's Joe Brandon was
doing it there yeah in the common area
him and his son Hunter were doing lines
in the cafeteria together yeah the White
House the Secret Service can't tell us
where they found it but then the other
thing is does anyone care like I just
don't care if people are doing cocaine I
don't yeah I don't give a [__] either
like I don't care but okay and we're
starting to believe that the reason they
won't tell us where they found it is
because that would tell us whose Coke it
was it was found on the office of the
the president's desk in the Oval Office
yeah
Secret Service isn't telling us anything
in response to a freedom of information
request put forward by Bloomberg the
Secret Service is saying they can't
release any records about the coke found
at the White House why they said it
would interfere with an ongoing
investigation
but that is actually true I mean if
they're doing an investigation they
don't want to give away their key
details it doesn't matter Jesse Waters
is it's for Jesse Waters is open and
shut
so let him handle it it's also been like
three days do not vote for Joe Biden
there was a small quantity of cocaine
found in the common area of the White
House Donald Trump is a Sudafed boy like
that's how he was uh getting Yak though
education
police charge people with cocaine
possession
they find it in someone
but today
we learned this house because it's Joe
Biden's house oh he lives there yeah
that's his right ultimately he's like Yo
dude whatever it's in your house your
accountant okay that's an interesting
Theory yeah
I hadn't thought about that yeah bi is a
part of the cover-up
as to how cocaine wound up at the White
House
uh yes I want to be a little bit careful
about what I can say here because sacred
service is leading the investigation but
as is standard in an investigation uh
where white powder is found uh the FBI's
lab Personnel did an evaluation to
determine whether or not there was a you
know sort of biological is that the only
assistant we have that's only assist
we've done so far we have offered the
full range of our assistance uh to the
Secret Service uh if they want to use us
oh they've done more than offer the FBI
is now involved in the White House Coke
investigation Christopher Ray and so
anyway this this is actually almost nine
minute segment so is the lead story
Monday Tuesday yeah this is huge what do
you what are you guys talking about it's
a big deal no you know what it is is
because and I we're in the same business
I'm in the same business as Jesse Waters
especially yes uh selling and
trafficking cocaine um
and it's a it's a dead period let's be
real people are on uh people are on
vacation they're not as like tapped into
the news the news cycle is kind of
boring and they can't talk about NATO
and Ukraine every goddamn day so they
got to find something else and they
think this is a a gift wrapped a
beautiful present for them to cover but
unfortunately it's a bit of a dud well
it's better than let's kill trans people
I guess it's an upgrade yeah oh the
media hypocrisy oh I love that here we
go they're wondering why are people not
taking this seriously multiple Diet
Cokes per day and even had a diet coke
button in the Oval Office this is how
the media reacted we see him go up and
down during the course of a day and it
may sometimes this is a special episode
this is okay this is a Fox News present
the Ingram angle special yeah times
depend on the supply of Diet Coke the
thing that would concern me more is this
consistent
um consumption of fats and sugars 12
Diet Cokes is a lot of Diet Coke and not
very healthy thing you know causes a lot
of things that you'd expect a lot of I
mean first of all I agree it's really
dumb that they're talking about Diet
Coke although to be fair 12 Diet Cokes
is great pretty I think it's perfectly
normal I think Trump's that many diet
drinks no but I think Trump did
everything right and they indicted him
okay that's I'm gonna say that 12 Diet
Cokes is healthy okay it's not at least
it's not real coke doctor IDs doctor it
has no problem right now frankly yep
yeah caffeine to cause irritability
insomnia sometimes become more focusing
you're talking about caffeine can shut
up [__] yeah [__] you Dr Sanjay Gupta
actual Coke in the white house not in a
can but in a line they by the way they
weren't like let's arrest Trump they're
like this is a silly funny story let's
talk about it yeah 100 yeah
no one was like this is a matter of
National Security that Trump is drinking
too many are not voting for Trump he's
slamming too many Diet Cokes folks we
got to do something about it this is
hypocrisy at its finest big joke
I would like to know Blow by blow who is
responsible for death
he did a joke about it injured as far as
We Know
and it's an illicit drug at the White
House why can't you actually have a bit
of fun with it I agree girl that's that
is pretty funny that they're saying
because that's what I said I don't
expect CNN to be like yeah it's just a
little bit of coach I'm gonna do it all
these media people who they do Coke this
is what fuels them on a daily basis
so I find it funny that all these people
are out here like I cannot believe
people do Coke it's like shut up I could
see the powder under your nose
yeah
so anyway that's hurting the Biden
campaign tremendously yeah no everyone's
really mad about that everybody is super
up in arms actually Trump made a tweet
about it uh which was really compelling
the public is demanding to know the
White House cocaine story just like I
quickly provided security tips for
Mar-A-Lago on the boxes hope Oaks the
White House has security cameras
far more than Mar-A-Lago okay all over
the place especially the location in
question they 100 know who it is if they
don't release information it means they
destroyed the tapes and the cocaine was
used for Hunter and probably even
crooked Joe Biden in order to give his
total disaster of presidency a little
life and energy I love this story
because like
like he's trying to compare it to the
boxes hoax right which is a hoax
but like that would imply that the
cocaine definitely was brought into the
White House in the same way that he
brought the classified documents in the
Mar-A-Lago so like what is he trying to
say here that like some random person
might have been able to bring the
documents classified documents that he
had access to in the Mar-A-Lago like you
did that I cannot get over his
scrumptious looking neck [__] oh yeah
he does he's easy
he's looking glorious I'll hang out I'm
telling you man get some just get a
little cover it up move in there and go
to town
get that off the screen hold on Dan can
I zoom in further I'm just saying Ian
we're gonna get a strike oh it's too
Graphics yeah it's too Graphics I'll
just give you a big fat kiss someone
needs to call him out on that neck [__]
I love I love uh you know Donald Trump
talking about [__] a president's son
doing cocaine by the way that's a joke
like have you seen Donald Trump Jr dude
he's [__] yaked out of his goddamn
mind literally always yeah uh let's see
other this other thing
how are you feeling about threads are
you into it at all I mean I haven't
really tweeted too much or I haven't
really threaded too much on it yeah it's
whatever I'm into threads for this
reason
I like it
I I think that Twitter going under and
Elon losing a 44 billion dollar
investment is so funny and obviously
Zuckerberg's a demon he's a musk is a
demon but of the two I mean I'm I find
it more funny
and what a display of incompetency of a
billionaire maybe like better than we've
ever seen
and so I'm on threads
I I want to see I want to see Elon Musk
Crash and Burn uh I'm one of his Tesla's
on autopilot yeah exactly and I want I
mean
Mark Zuckerberg basically was one of the
least liked billionaires uh out of all
the public profile having billionaires
he was always really seen as like a
weird lizard guy
and then he started doing Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu
he started getting absolutely peeled
svelt shredded I don't know if you saw
um have you seen the photo with him and
Israel lasagna oh my God he looks
shredded dude wait he's got [__] gutters
does he okay yeah so basically what
Zuckerberg did oh cut like a six-pack no
[__] gutters Ethan what's a six V's what
the dick bees the come gutters oh that's
a [__] gun I've never heard of that
that's really vulgar bro so uh my point
is he in all of his like lizard uh brain
Antics he found that like there's one
other public uh public profile having
billionaire that he could absolutely
eviscerate and make himself look good by
uh comparing himself to this guy and
it's [__]
Elon Musk so now he's making elamas look
like a baby all the time wait he is he
looks great he is
roll uh he's a little bit uh younger
than you I believe you know no wait
really oh Ethan's 43s no I'm 38 stop
it's not funny
I don't want to mislead the people
uh he's 39. so he's one year older than
me what that looks like an AI photo oh
it is 39. that yeah but so here okay so
you know how people they've been doing
this like they show a picture of um
what's that mean with a the Kennedy guys
he's five seven so he's like close to
your height and close to your age 39.
he's older and shorter
it's a little bit shorter 39. the one of
of the Kennedy guy who's jacked and then
they compared him to
you know I'm talking about RFK yeah RFK
they're like he's jacked he's not
oh yeah that that poor doctor that was
getting harassed oh yeah the guy that
was on okay the guy with the bow tie
show it just pull it up so people know
what I'm talking about because that was
my favorite meme because it
automatically just shows that you're the
dumbest guy on the planet he's like who
would you rather get health advice from
and then on the one hand you have like a
jacked anti-vaxxer and then on the other
hand you have a doctor
like you're just telling on yourself at
that point okay I have I I have a really
good meme format that I'm coming out
with but I think this is going to hit
hard against Elon Musk okay Pam is
working on it right now but uh yeah Mark
I mean damn he looks good I'd like to
come in his gutters for sure
like to fill him up
good for him though he's living his best
life yeah I mean he has uh unlimited
access he has like the best personal
trainers he also [__] doesn't have
that weird Caesar cut anymore so that's
good yeah well that [__] was not doing
him any favors
uh yeah so anyway
um the reason I bring it up is because
things are happening on Twitter that
make it
for me even harder to uh support the
platform even in the sense of using it
um Tucker has an exclusive Twitter show
as we've oh my God he okay so Tucker
literally flew out to Romania yeah to
interview Tate he's so sad what the [__]
this man flew out to Romania it was that
important to interview Andrew Tate
I love all the Q Anon Tucker fans who
were like oh we want to stop Democrats
from sex trafficking and then they're
like but this sex trafficker he's he
seems like a good guy he's one of the
good ones he's one of the good sex
traffickers he's a white hat I mean
Tucker goes on and on about like we must
stop the degeneracy and abuse of young
women anyway I'm flying out to Romania
to interview my good friend uh Andrew
Tate even if he wasn't a sex trafficker
the fact that like he ran an only fan
scheme that's yeah is enough for the
normal conservative audience that
immediately be like no [__] this guy
so anyway so Elon Musk I'm assuming paid
for this I don't I don't know but I'm
assuming because Tucker works for
Twitter now or so he tweets this out
interesting interview with Cobra Tate so
he's co-signing this oh uh so here let
me tell you why this happened okay this
is in many respects no different than
when Aiden Ross or any other content
creator hits the Andrew Tate button
because like it'll feed the algo right
Tucker Carlson started off uh in a blaze
of glory okay uh he had so many views
even though like those are Impressions
they're fake for the most part on
Twitter especially so uh and he started
off with that he started out with a lot
of views and everyone was like oh my God
this is beating TV this is beating TV
Tucker Carlson's doing great and
obviously people that understand the
situation better people like myself who
have been in this game doing political
commentary online for a very long time
immediately recognized that this was
[__] and that it was always going to
crash and burn so by like his eighth
episode obviously his Impressions had
diminished those impressions are already
like pretty useless as a metric for
success in general because it's [__]
Twitter
um
but by the eighth episode they had he
had lost 83.
83 of his overall views
right so what does he do he puts the he
pulls the Andrew Tate uh parachute he
rips the cord he goes all the way to
Romania he reduces himself to that he
debases himself this way and he goes and
interviews Andrew Tate for two hours and
30 minutes on Twitter and and he's he's
he's
laundering His Image I mean he the
amount of research has been really
beneficial watch this just watch how
Andrew characterizes his crimes it's
stunning
imagine being a sixth grade boy in the
United States right now that's weird
that is so great that's a strong start
and grooming strong start from Tucker I
refuse to imagine that what are you
hearing at school what are they telling
you on the internet
well they're telling you to stop being
yourself sit still stop joking suppress
your aggression share your feelings obey
share your feelings God she Whiz
Milk porn
female thought that was or virtually I
thought he said he did exploding
milkborn exploding milk to us masculine
qualities are oppressive that's the
message in case it wasn't clear enough
schools around the country have removed
urinals and here is what is in my
opinion the greatest male role model
Andrew Tate
from boys bathrooms the male body itself
is shameful there's no [__] they're not
removing urinals from boys bathrooms
that's so dumb sit down when you pee
like a good little girl what that's it
you're saying that that's an insane
thing to just have a sound bite of
imagine you're a six-year-old boy
and then I invite you over to my house I
say this is between us you understand
that right oh sorry I mean at school
views like this are often called
feminism
feminism 16 year old boys to sit to pee
I don't know if Tucker Carlson knows
this but like even if you eliminate
urinals uh you can still pee standing up
in in like a regular bathroom stall
but he does not know that it's not
illegal man I do it all the time I have
a feeling I just I'm worried that he's
thinking about six-year-old boys too
much yeah he said that that is a lot of
that's like 90 of conservative comments
don't ask me to think about that Tucker
again very weird very strange but in
fact they amount to mass conversion
therapy an attempt to change the
fundamental nature of people what
nothing like this has ever been
attempted at scale it's one of the most
they're living in such a fantasy world
it's just like this doesn't exist and
destructive experiments in human history
what would it be like to find yourself
doesn't even exist of that experiment as
a boy trying to become a man during the
Biden years
well you might kill yourself during the
Biden when you have oh you might decide
to reject your own manhood and embrace
it anyway that's as well I'm trying to
skip to the is that the good part here
has has been the video is long but if
you can take the time to watch it make
up your own mind please watch it so he
goes this is great he goes make up your
own mind about Andrew Tate meanwhile the
way that he's engaging with him is
literally the puffiest thing ever listen
to how he allows Andrew to characterize
his crimes this is a musical this is a
mutually beneficial situation Tucker
Carlson wants the Andrew Tate
algorithmic boost because like there's
not a lot of Andrew Tate out there right
now and people want it I get it I get
why he did it it's just so pathetic yeah
then Elon for Elon to quote tweet it and
be like yo check out this super
interesting interview it's like with the
with the conv with a sex trafficker
under house arrest yeah
so what are you charged with that's a
really good question first of all love
the money Gorillas with being the head
of an organized criminal Group which is
in charge of recruiting girls to make
Tick Tock videos to steal the money from
The Tick Tock views that's that's not
what it is that's not true I'm I'm
making women do tick tocks that's what
he's reduced it to and Tucker does not
ever
push back on that he's like oh yeah no
that sounds absurd yeah the one the only
thing that's like kind of funny about
this is that
Dave basically
manipulated a gigantic swath of the
internet
into literally believing that this is a
man that is being unjustly prosecuted
and
I guess they're all going to be really
shocked if he does go to go to prison
he's definitely going to prison and
and instead of uh getting snapped out of
their illusions
or their delusions rather they will
continue for going further and further
down the the rabbit hole of
schizophrenia
set up it was he was set up yeah
recruiting girls to make Tick-Tock
videos and stealing the money so that
sounds absurd you're right I it looks
that way and it's very interesting
because the girls who they've identified
to add to the file are saying that we're
not victims of anything and this isn't
true
but the state believes it's true and the
state thinks the I as a 35 year old man
woke up this [__] wears the
tightest sleeves bro
every time he's got just like the the
he's got the extra small fit yeah no
he's got the gay style like it's just
it's it's it's ridiculous that like he's
hold on look at Tucker's shoes yeah I
mean that's just preppy he's prep boy
but no the no socks thing is killing me
that's normally you're supposed to wear
it like that
I disagree I think no you are a good
pair of uh Italian loafers they're not
they don't get stinky they're supposed
to be like breathable enough it's not
working it looks like he's wearing high
heels
well he's preppy I I hate Andrew Tate's
uh slippers more than I hate Tucker
Carlson's loafers in this situation not
to be like that die work wear guy on
[__] Twitter but
Tucker Carlson is doing the classic
preppy wasp uh Northeastern guy
look I was already extremely financially
successful I was already a father I was
already very well known I had no
finances how'd you get the money
I do get the money
hmm how did you how are you that'd be a
good follow-up question maybe Tucker
will last how did you make all your
money
I uh yeah I had I owned a webcam
business
the question would be uh but it seems
like you made your money uh before Tick
Tock existed how does that work yeah
just just one simple basic follow-up
question would be fantastic no criminal
record it's not my personality profile
but I woke up the age of 35 and decided
to he has no criminal record he was uh
he is was
charged with rape in the UK he was he
was accused but uh they never charged
him in the UK and then there was an
internal investigation with the UK
police that found that they were just
flubbing sexual assault like yeah there
was criminal negligence yeah uh at the
systemic level girls do tick tock to
enrich myself with the pennies that I
would earn from Tick Tock views yeah
that sounds silly so in the United
States the I think the belief is that
you were charged with human trafficking
yeah that's human trafficking because
what you do is you force a girl to work
against her will for financial gain
that's human trafficking why is he
saying I believe like he doesn't know
like this is all like public this man
flew to Romania and he didn't read up
yeah on the flight there you could have
just like look at one Article 15 hours
probably no it's not 50
you can't probably fly direct maybe okay
who cares it's significant bro 12 hours
that's fine that's enough time to do a
little reading oh 100 justification for
this is that girls do Tick Tock some
girls I know who they found who say
they're not victims have Tick Tock
accounts how do you force someone to do
Tick Tock videos like a good question
explain that isn't he uh how do you
force a girl to do a tick tock I mean it
doesn't make sense on its face how do
you force a girl to do a tick tock video
what I'm confused by this is like even
if he actually forced girls to do Tick
Tock videos that would still be coercion
and also would be like a labor violation
possibly even human trafficking
depending on the boundaries where he's
pulling this Tick Tock thing is in the
indictments they do mention Tick Tock in
addition to him forcing them to work on
only fans and all of this other stuff
but it's not to make Tick-Tock videos he
would make girls do those like Tick-Tock
battle things you know oh um for like
10-hour marathons
also well also I mean there's a lot of
um oh they were bad battle bits who
promote themselves on tick tock not for
tick tock Revenue right but to promote
their other business so it's like how
obtuse can you be you [__] dominant
Jade has a son or a child by the way I
guess yeah he's completely uninvolved in
his life I'm sure
kind of like he's a very interesting
scenario I'm in and I'm inside of
Romania so I have to show a degree of
respect to the Romanian judicial system
and I have to show a degree of respect
to the situation I'm in but wait a
degree of respect of the Romanian
Judicial System yeah he literally openly
used to be like in Romania you can bribe
the police that's why I came here to be
a criminal like you can't be a criminal
like Jeffrey Epstein in America with the
amount of with the small amount of
dollars I have so I went to Romania so I
can be a mini Jeffrey Epstein in Romania
by bribing the officials they love
getting bribes and then Tucker's like so
tell me how do you force a girl to even
do a tick tock overall charge is that
there's an organized criminal group
there's a group of us I'm the head of it
my brother is the below me and we use
the Loverboy method to convince women to
do Tick Tock videos to make money so
that we can steal the tick tock money
that's just absolutely false you're so
crazy it's actually it's actually a big
L for him though because he's basically
validating the claims of the
investigation by saying oh it's just
look how silly it is it's just for tick
tock okay that will open up the door to
be like well it's not just Tick Tock
it's also a webcaming business that you
also promoted yourself they already know
that it's just he's he's allowing him to
wash his reputation entirely yeah but um
it's it's again easily dismissable
because like instead of just saying
there's no truth to these claims he's
admitting uh some of those claims to
make it seem like they're I don't think
he's admitting to them he's just saying
look how silly these charges are yeah I
don't know I think I think this is uh
worse off for his uh PR because like no
way dude you can open up fans love this
this will give him so much credibility
[__] they're as dumb as sea cucumbers
so like and there's a lot of anything to
his fans thought he was like out of
prison in the first day they would come
into my chat every [__] day because
I've like every goddamn Twitter meme
account uh that that tweets on God every
[__] day they all they all hate me
now because I eviscerated Andrew today
and they dick ride him super hard uh for
the algo not because they're
ideologically aligned with them or
anything and they they all [__] tell
me every day how wrong I am because they
think like Andrew Tate is out of prison
already or Andrew Tate is actually
getting released any day now
um there he's drip feeding them [__]
non-stop that has to at a certain point
get people to go okay well he's lied to
me a bunch of times
I think every time you lie like that you
lose a at least some of your audience
okay
you tell me whose platform is better
sucks
or elons I mean Zuck looks hot exactly
open and shut this is how conservatives
gauge
Batman bad goofy weird body fat man bad
you know what he's a beautiful body
because we don't make fun of people's
bodies
even though it does look like there's a
mini robot Batman bad this is like this
is Batman bad no because strong man good
no this isn't even fat man better
because like Elon Musk isn't necessarily
fat he just has like the weirdest
[__] body of all time it literally
looks like his chest has expanded so
much I don't know how I don't know why
he's looks like um you know in Ninja
Turtles there's like that guy that rides
inside of a body he's like a brain crane
yeah crying he's giving me crying vibes
from this it's like a little
um it's a little habitat for a little
critter to drive his body
you know what I'm saying seem cool
yeah like the Men in Black thing yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there's a
little alien living inside of him
operating his body which would make some
pulley system
yeah
so uh here this is what Elon is giving I
guess uh if that makes sense to anybody
yeah yeah
crank thank you problem is he didn't
pick a better body to you know a better
looking body at least to [__] sit
inside of so anyway uh I'll keep going
just briefly again this is two and a
half hours so there's no just to be
clear you are not accused of pandering
of pimping and forcing women to have sex
with anybody no not fortunate he is he's
also accused of of our wording women
yeah he's he's accused of sexual assault
as well as uh sex trafficking he he
literally is Tucker and by the way
you're a journalist right
well not really well more I mean at
least an interviewer some kind of thing
like did you do zero preparation let me
just hide as a 35 year old man woke up
decided to make and that's human
trafficking and their justification for
this is that girls do Tick-Tock some
girls I know who they found who say
they're not victims have Tick Tock
accounts how do you force someone to do
Tick-Tock videos
I do this because
I I do think it's a widespread belief
that you were accused of pimping yeah
well there's nothing to do with any of
this case absolutely nothing and it's
kind of scary because the crime in
itself of human trafficking is a unique
one because they can ignore the
statement of the victim so the girls
have come forward and said this is
insane you've just no literally this
investigation started when women came to
the police yeah several of them and told
them about what was happening yeah he's
just pointing to like a couple that
still have Andrew Tate tattoos on their
bodies saying like no we actually do
love him
so pretty stunning that the whole this
is at this point mainstream
the entire right-wing apparatus is now
somehow involved in whitewashing Andrew
Tate a human trafficker and rapist
reputation here is Tucker Carlson
being promoted by Elon Musk
it's I mean imagine I don't know why I
don't know what's happening I mean
here's why it never has mattered right
these guys all talk about like how
Jeffrey Epstein is like connected to
Hillary Clinton and Bill Clinton which
is true he was but then they [__]
have Alan dershowitz on every time every
night they have Alan dershowitz on Alan
dershow was was Jeffrey Epstein's friend
just like the Hillary and Bill Clinton
uh couple but also he was his greatest
Defender he got him out of like a
serious
um sex trafficking and and uh pedophilia
charge I mean he practically had like a
guest house on that island amount of
times he went yeah it was like an
honored guest there which is why it's
like these guys don't care the point is
nobody cares they just nobody even asks
that question nobody's like hold up wait
a minute why are you talking about
Virginia Joffrey uh why are you talking
about like some of Jeffrey Epstein's
victims and like disparaging them on Fox
News every [__] night
um aren't isn't this supposed to be the
anti-sex trafficking uh uh television
network I don't understand and here's
our good friend Alan dershowitz give it
up for Alan everybody
[Music]
um here is some Choice clips from the
two and a half hour interview uh Tucker
asks Andrew what is the Matrix
question
I guess some Americans call it the Deep
state but I like to look at it in a more
Global way when I say the Matrix I think
there are certain agendas which are
being pushed I think the media machine
and the Judicial Systems of the world
work together hand in hand I think the
goal is to control people's minds to a
point where they don't discuss anything
that's important the reason I use the
Matrix is because I've watched that
movie a few times and it has so many
similarities to the have you seen the
movie no you've never okay that's
disturbing that Tucker hasn't seen The
Matrix I find that very odd it's about
to get more disturbing and then yeah in
the movie The Matrix no I don't watch
any movies
no I'm very um dyslexic and it's hard
for me to watch video got it what no I'm
I'm slightly dyslexic but I don't think
that one has to do with the other I
don't think so what the [__] wait that's
what I've never heard that before that's
an interesting out it's a medium that
has nothing to do with like reading
letters really so I don't know if
there's like a severe or separate case
where like you can't look at stuff but
how is that possible his whole job is
media and reading stuff and reading
[__] well I don't know if he's
reading anything let's be real he
definitely was reading off teleprompters
that's true though yeah so he doesn't
watch anything that could explain why
he's so horribly researched
he's like I cannot never watch anything
I cannot watch anything ever
that's why I'm incapable of doing I've
never seen a motion picture what is film
I don't even know what it looks like
frankly it's it's subtitles I think like
that would be a problem if you have
dyslexia sure
but his ears work as far as I know
honestly understood but there's so many
similarities and the basic premise is
that humans minds are controlled and put
inside of a false reality their body
heat can be manifested for the mission
yes and I don't think it's much
different to reality our mind we're
putting transistors yeah we're told
things aren't true we're arguing over
things that don't matter we're observed
shut up dumbass
so anyway Tucker's a little weirdo also
an allegory for being trans but it's
fine I mean he's just
placing it a couple times degrees right
he's talking about how the Matrix is
like you know this this deep state
conspiracy to to brainwash people and I
assume you know trans ideology is part
of that brainwashing if that's the case
isn't the make the Matrix is part of
that plant
like that's media that is indoctrinating
people into yeah I don't know my mind is
exploding it's expanding at alarming
levels what if the Matrix was a part of
the Matrix now it's just it's so stupid
it's just like typical dumb guy [__] it
is literally typical dumb guy [__] the
more illiterate we become I saw
something the other day that uh really
hit me uh
it was someone complaining that because
we have access to boundless amounts of
information readily available on your
phones through the internet that we
don't really do any kind of reading or
try to uh try to learn anything because
we can always just like Ask Google so
we've become over reliant on that and
therefore now we are basically as
illiterate as a [__] medieval peasant
so now we're just tricked and shocked by
things like movies for example like this
Andrew Tate himself is a charlatan he's
probably a little bit smarter than the
average person that he's duping right so
he probably knows better
he knows that this is a good way to like
do PR for himself but there is a
gigantic swath of people online that
hear that and go yeah it is the Matrix
the governments are controlling us in
this like big deep state conspiracy to
do what to like give us vaccinations and
make us trans that's probably what's
going on
let me show you creators
of mate what are they called the
wachowskis Makowski sisters yeah
here they are there's these Legends
oh man don't show him this these these
two gals made the Matrix trans women do
not tell them that yeah they just don't
care it's the same principle behind it
is uh the same identical principle
behind having Alan dershowitz on or even
having Andrew [__] taton
uh
on your on your broadcast is you're like
you know saying Democrats are the real
sex traffickers right it's just it's
[__] so here's Benny Johnson who's a
right-wing grifter he's posted this I
guess as a dub he's like man check these
guys out so smart so good what is it
about your message do you think that
infuriates certain people well my
message traditional my message is
traditional masculinity my message is to
stand up and say what you mean and mean
what you say and even going to the gym
nowadays is an act of defiance because
when you
going to the gym is an act of defiance
that's all I love that it's this is
another byproduct of like the
pulsification of of uh Western Society
we're all babies right like so they're
doing this with the new the new movie
that uh that just came out about child
sex trafficking right the gym
now as far as I understand I haven't
seen it yet the way that they're
promoting it it was an old movie they
made it in 2018 but there was not really
a market for it but then
um they found the studios found a good
way to like rehash this project and
re-uh basically upload it and and you
know post it everywhere by promoting it
through Q Anon conspiracies and Q Anon
circles a little bit so
now all of these people that are going
to watch it are like oh we're doing
something this is an act of defiance
it's like no you're just going to watch
a movie Nobody watched the taken
franchise and went wow I'm really
shining a dark uh shining a light on the
dark side of child sex trafficking right
you just watch the [__] movie but it
can't just be that it has to be our our
consumption has to say something about
us our consumption has to be an act of
defiance it's an act of Bravery that's
why all these people that are like
leaving the movie theaters are like I
had a less than remarkable experience at
the movie theater watching the sound of
freedom because the AC was off or the
lights were on and guess what uh guess
what George Soros like I still watch the
movie I still completed it am I not a
big boy or a big girl look at me it's
just no you're going to the gym it's not
a [__] act of defiance it's really no
one is yelling at Andrew Tate because
he's saying go to the gym gym culture is
like so dominant right now it's like
actually insanely mainstream or like a
lot of these like I don't know Alpha
dudes it's like they live their whole
life in the gym yeah the the problem
there is uh some of the best people I
know are gym rats they're Jim Bros
because they have uh maybe some
insecurities from the start that led
them to do this or maybe they just
wanted to be healthy but after a certain
point that feeling of accomplishing
goals that you have uh set out for
yourself will start to develop
confidence within you right and
ultimately if you're a confident person
who has uh accomplished certain
tremendously difficult tasks such as
reshaping your body in the way that you
see fit
um you're not going to believe this
[__] like it was very important for
me what I was able to accomplish in the
gym which is why I talk about uh it in a
positive way all the time
and and that is part of the reason why
I'm not falling down the Andrew Tate
rabbit hole because I have a sense of
security within myself within what I can
accomplish so Andrew Tate is not the
only person who's like telling people to
go out and work out and whatever but
maybe I hope these guys if they go to
the gym a lot and they start working out
more and more they'll they'll start
getting a better sense of self and no
longer be these like insecure babies
um
I'm not sure about that one um maybe one
or two I don't know you have a man who's
built with any degree of principle you
say no to things and I think if I have
to analyze my message and why I'm so
disliked by the people who dislike me
it's not the things I'm saying it's the
fact that it's the things I'm doing like
human trafficking if you adhere to my
principles and you adhere to the things
I say and rape not being the kind of
person who will resist certain ideas you
say no what kind of man never says no
name a man who never says no okay I
would name a person that's never said no
like a man who never I have never said
no ever
it's so stupid it's like oh men say no
and that's why people are mad at me and
it's like it depends on what you're
saying no to them you mean like a like
the uh Married with Children like can I
have money Dad no yeah it's just like oh
well uh a real man says no that's why
yeah that's why when um when I was in a
car crash because a female was driving
my Bugatti and the EMS came over and
said would you like a ride to the
hospital I don't know because I'm a man
and real men take it
ironic because that is kind of what I
did in France but it's different how
about this say yes if you are innocent
of human trafficking no
we got him [__] got him we [__]
got him remaining authorities need
there's a tip to the prosecutor dicot
needs you on their side men say no right
men men wake up and say no I don't think
that should be done this way no it
doesn't even make sense and Tucker's
like yeah my children will not be taught
that no father's primary job that's the
father's primary job to say no to
everything fantastic that could explain
why you guys are the way you are like
that's why I'm teaching my son how to do
chemistry do you love me no I don't want
the teacher to teach my son algebra I'm
going to do that myself
there's uh yeah do you want to come do
you want to play uh baseball with me no
will you sp will you sit with me and
help me with my homework no it's just
like that active Defiance can be a valid
one which Andrew Tate is trying to claim
his is or it can be what a [__] child
does I'll how about this should you wait
wait until uh that girl is able at that
age of consent no Andrew Kate has said
that do you think that women should have
the freedom to uh work on their own and
be employed without the inclusion of a
pseudo pimp no
can I leave the compound Andrew no no
yeah real men say no and you can you at
least let the guard with the automatic
uh rifle uh just can you just excuse him
for the afternoon so I don't feel
threatened no
it's it's uh you know it's an active
Defiance and uh I feel like it's more so
like what a baby says where it's like
real men say no to nap time my parents
wanted me to wear diapers and I told
them no I'm gonna piss and [__] on the
floor because that's what a real man
does yep know to nap time I'm having
candy for dinner and you can't stop me
Mom and Dad because real men say no and
the reason why I'm using that get off me
no yeah the reason why I'm using that as
an analogies because that's like
literally real men no that's his
audience that's that's it's either 12
year olds or in a sadder way older men
that have uh never mentally matured
beyond the age of 12. so that's why it's
like when he makes these super simple uh
takes when he has these super simple
tags it's like it's very appealing to
this broad audience
hey uh Andrew uh should I fill out this
uh form that says I've paid taxes to the
government no I'll do it
he's a he's a real man actually
absolutely when you say to men listen
you're allowed to have an opinion you're
allowed to have standards you're allowed
to have boundaries and all the history
of all the world men are finally allowed
to have opinions about things finally
you're allowed to get up and become
important and work hard and try to
become the kind of man who can't be
controlled finally then you're seen as
an enemy and I especially with the
massive influence I've gained
I think they look at me and go ah he's
helping men resist the slave program yep
that's why I'm around nothing to do with
the human trafficking array this is the
funniest part about it because it brains
the funniest part about it is that like
all of the stuff that Andrew Tate's dick
riders claim they used to Claim about
Jordan Peterson as well and it's like
the most basic [__] he he says no one is
going to prison for saying go to the gym
no one's even going to prison for saying
like reject trans ideology if that was
the case then and the world would be a
much better place let's be real but
Michael Knowles would be [__] under
the jail Matt Walsh would not even be in
jail he would be a cloud of pink Mist
okay that's not how this works there are
people out there that are significantly
more transphobic than Andrew Tate and
they're perfectly fine you want to know
why because the investigations have not
been conducted uh yet and we don't know
if they are allegedly uh sex trafficking
uh Andrew will you ever be free again no
thank you
Andrew do you are you able to get it up
no well he he also doesn't even like sex
do you like sex at all no no he has
talked about that he's like I don't like
stats anymore it's too easy it's still
like I don't like it
okay I mean that's fine so he's asexual
yeah he's uh he's part of the LGBT II WT
uh he's an ally yeah he's part of that I
like Ace he's I'm Ace aromantic yeah Ace
is [__] people I love Ace people because
people are gonna get mad at you for that
by the way they're gonna be like don't
don't Loop them in with us even though I
mean he is listen guys he's Ace we need
to we need we need a bigger tent
I think Trump is Ace but that's a
different story
do asexual I'm not trying to demean I'm
genuinely curious and you guys might not
know do asexual people masturbate
uh some do yeah I think some do yeah
just curious or if it's just like the
total lack of interest in anything I
think that's probably a spectrum like
anything and some age people also have
sex as well for their for their Partners
even if they don't personally do enjoy
their own personal gratification right
asexual people might still masturbate or
have sex after all sexuality doesn't
always mean someone doesn't enjoy sex it
just means they don't experience sexual
attraction oh okay so it's about the
attraction
they're not attracted to anyone wow
that's Ace
so we can inject the slave programming
and convince men to be eunuchs because
once you're Unix yes and you're not a
threat
I think I buy that
[Laughter]
he should have asked him about his Megan
Fox thing because he's like I would
rather have sex with trans Megan Fox
yeah than a women a CIS woman that looks
like Hulk Hogan yeah right right because
he's like he he has said some stuff in
the past
just like Donald Trump has that is like
you know because these guys are they
don't have like genuinely held opinions
they're just kind of uh tailoring their
messaging uh they they are bigoted for
sure but then they also like tailor
their messaging across like uh whatever
is is really popping on social media
but ever seemingly has a big audience so
uh both him and Donald Trump in the past
have had you know Pro trans takes so
that's what uh Tucker Carlson should ask
him about
Benny Johnson uh again remember he
posted this clip in full sincerity and
Elon Musk is promoting this clip I mean
it's really it makes this whole Twitter
experience uh hard to
hard to use in my opinion I just think
that
it's getting harder and harder to be on
there man for me
um but let's see there's
um one more here wait Andrew Tate's
shading adam22 are you [__] serious
yeah this blew my mind like this is such
a weird crossover that like Tucker is
talking about Adam 20. that is so
interesting you know you followed the
atom 22 stuff where his yeah I'm
familiar I think adam22 did a very
brilliant marketing move to like move
the attention away from the Adam 16
conversation and also simultaneously
like
everyone's gonna watch the cuck porn now
because he's just been promoting his
cuck porn the truth but the thing is
like it seems like a lot of his fans are
people who are like being a cuck is the
worst being a beta don't ever ever do it
so
that's interesting can you still buy the
only fans so who gives a [__] for sure
they they did major numbers with that
uh but here it is I don't want to make
personal enemies of people I don't know
there's a guy called adam22 once again I
have no idea this is awesome
they're talking about the most important
news stories of the day huge okay Adam
22 got cucked yeah his wife had sex with
a dude with a black dude with a huge
Cocker have you seen Jason loves penis I
mean it's ridiculous it's like a thermos
it's massive it's glorious
which you know a friend of the show
Jason love shouts out to Jason love and
I would way rather [__] Jason love with
a [__] than uh Rosie O'Donnell with a
[__] Jason whatever Jason love is uh
Jason loves those six foot five it's
disgusting he's got it all it's [__]
up okay shut the [__] up I'm just saying
he's like he's the man shut up I like
Jason yeah listen I'm not I got nothing
with Jake wrong with Jason
but it is I just saw on Twitter
yesterday
that he was with a porn star who'd never
done a male scene
they got married and like a week after
their marriage she did her first male
scene with some random dude and he's on
a podcast defending it
that his wife had sex with somebody else
correct
why uh dude
how does this matter at all anything
like wow people have different kinds of
relationships dude
at a certain point Tucker Carlson has to
in this two hour and 30 minute interview
in the [__] compound okay in the rape
compound like he has to take a deep
breath to himself and just just really
recollect his thoughts and go what has
happened to my career I used to
interview presidents
I used to have a like Stranglehold on
domestic and even sometimes foreign
policy in the United States of America
apparently Adam sleeps regularly with
other women does he do porn with other
women is that what it is oh yeah so Adam
had a podcast where they would interview
porn stars female porn stars yeah and
then it would [__] them okay together
yeah okay I see I see
what a life
this is the level you could that this
but this is what the Matrix wants from
you as a man this Matrix wants your wife
to [__] J what's his name
uh Jason love Jason love Yeah The Matrix
once you're you'd have let your wife
[__] Jason love don't you understand I
thought don't you get it the Matrix was
media and judicial system no does that
have to do with that that makes one's
got a huge [__] and it wants to [__]
your wife yeah don't you understand they
want the woman in charge and the man
below with no backbone because if the
woman's in charge they can emotionally
affect her they can scare her you can
scare a woman right you scare a man yes
a real man's hard to scare right a woman
you can make afraid of the vaccine are
you scared no also all this doesn't
sound that different than his business
model right like he
he seduces women and are like kind of
sort of with them but then he pimps them
out for porn and he also like
basically cooking all of his clients too
because it was him who was writing all
the messages on the chat room right
right never the actual women themselves
well they're beta losers he's the he's
the real man yeah well those very same
beta losers he's still serving he was
serving them with his cam operation and
now he's serving them with a Hustlers
University which is no longer in
existence so and now he's being served
with search warrants yeah
thank you
all right be afraid covet be scared if
she's in charge of the household I would
argue in nearly any household where the
female was dominant everyone's
vaccinated
I don't want to make perfect that is
that is so true that is so true
so here is the meeting of great minds
and this is what Twitter's come to
and uh there it is shout out adam22.
it's just like
two Ace Legends right here man they're
just getting stupider and stupid we are
getting dumber and [__] Dumber dude
listen Trump might be ace but with that
neck [__] on display I sure am not oh
yeah Trump I don't think has ever had
like uh interest in sexual gratification
that works coercive or was like just
about or pure power and dominance over
another person outside of uh their
boundaries look at the shine on that
Dome brother yeah
you could put out a search Signal with
that because I'm surprised he shaved his
beard and his hair it looked like [__]
for the longest time
loved those two guys great guys running
mate Andrew Tate
VP yeah I mean he is for he was born in
Gary Indiana
he was born in a city named Gary you
don't know about Gary Indiana city named
Gary yeah The Music Man
it's Gary Indiana a wonderful blossoming
industrial town uh with a uh it was like
a it was like a industrial it was a
black industrial town uh for the most
part and then obviously it went by way
of uh the same way that Detroit did
why'd they call it Gary that's like
having a a city called Jeff or some [__]
yeah
okay Shout Out Gary
dub the city of Gary it's like pretty
desolate now kind of sad yeah I mean
very sad I drove by once and I said
welcome to Gary Indiana the home of big
old titties
spray painted it yeah wait what does
that mean they just spray painted the oh
okay the main sign when you drive in wow
this town doesn't look really uh well
it's it's definitely from what I
understand it's gotten a lot better in
recent years it's no longer as bad how
it works to be but it's not it's still
not great it's like I mean there's so
many places like this Gary smash that
button
[Music]
yeah is it gay that he was born in Gary
no because it's a man's name and he was
born in it I don't think that's how that
works I'm just saying I'm I'm just going
by his name he's very zesty he for sure
is very zesty and I think a lot of
people will recognize that I mean he's
like God damn it there is a city named
Jeff
in Indiana too oh no
oh [__] what other goddamn okay
breaking news literally right now I went
and checked it because I saw some Buzz
about it they're having their press
conference uh sag after a go ahead just
announced right now going on strike that
impacts thousands if not millions of
people they are going on strike oh my
God and around the world that's insane
not only like that like Tom Cruise and
all the way down can't act anymore
correct they can't even they can't be
scavs they're out I mean they can but
they get kicked out of the union and
they wouldn't be able to work on any
Studio movies anymore yeah yeah that's
[__] incredible that's wow yeah
that's a big deal oops hey up [__]
that's gonna make the that's gonna give
a lot of juice to the to the writer
strike too obviously because
um
now it's not just the writers it's the
actors too it's hard to make a movie
without those two things pretty hard
well I'm also on strike from doing the
dishes
sorry that's crazy sorry
this is cute she's actually huge news
that's very big news yeah I mean I was
kind of impressed with the size of these
um
these unions I mean that one has like a
hundred and sixty thousand yeah these
are these are some of the last like
remaining big powerful unions in in
North America other than like uh the
teamsters
and then who are also who are also maybe
going to go on strike well many members
are in the writers field yeah
the UPS like the commercial part of that
but Teamsters also like even if they
don't personally like the teamsters uh
Hollywood Union even if they don't go on
strike they have a policy of not
Crossing picket lines so if it's both
sag-aftra and the wga on strike together
uh a lot of Productions uh in in North
America will shut down completely yep
good for them
get it cheers
love you let's see uh yeah well
hopefully uh you know if media
completely stops being produced that
daddy's gonna catch some traffic over
here
tell all your friends H3 podcast is in
um there's one more clip I guess we can
end on as we come to the end of our
episode here Benny Johnson who we were
just talking about
this guy's such an idiot I do want to
say I wanted to have a whole section of
people like Benny or Tim Poole and the
quartering and everybody salivating over
this Tucker thing
not that much juice out there Benny
Johnson is one of the only ones I could
find that was like really horned up
about it like even the quartering was
like uh whatever yeah I think it's
literally too long for them to care
about I think that really hurts it at
like two and a half hours is a big
and apparently there was no really good
clippable moments I mean he's just doing
his greatest he's just doing the
greatest hits he's got nothing new to
say no we've heard it all but anyway
here's Benny Benny boy uh salivating
over this interview
[Music]
with a photo of him and Tucker Carlson
the two most uncancelable men on the
well does being arrested Countess I mean
he's going to be in jail pretty soon
literally got fired from his job for
being a [__] psycho
yeah but now he's got his own Twitter
now he's a Twitter vlogger flying to
Romania for exclusives in literal rape
dungeons sitting in front of money
gorillas
I wasn't kidding about the horned up
part wait for it okay dude now I know
you're full of [__]
why why are you trying to embarrass
money cover gorilla between them
I have never seen anything as a grown
man why are you not embarrassed to be
talking about like talking like this I
mean it's just humiliating with the
interview drop well actually just one
hour ago two weeks from when that tweet
was two and a half hours it dropped an
hour ago you're so pathetic
clearly just trying to get them clicks
boy
Carlson drops this interview Nyon one
hour ago got 2.3 million views it's a
impression 190 minutes
it's two and a half hours we've gone
through the interview and we have
flipped out some of the most amazing
comments wait hold on hold on he says
it's
290 minutes
I didn't catch him I don't remember what
he said he said 290 minutes
which would be five hours
did you say that yeah hold on hold on
hold on let me go back
this I didn't catch her the first time
90 minutes sir weeks from when that
tweet was sent Tucker Carlson drops this
interview Nyon one hour ago it got 2.3
million views it's a
190 minutes 190 190 minutes but I still
think no that's that that match yeah
definitely everybody watched it that's
3.1 hours yeah right it's not quite five
hours
try it try harder he tried
it's two and a half hours we've gone
through the interview I and we have
clipped out some of the most amazing
conversations he said it came out an
hour ago
they watch it in of this intro reaction
Kamala Harris on the power of
masculinity on the uh covid crisis and
the lies about Ukraine you know who I'm
and you know what Benny's giving me a
wall can you pull up the uh Rhonda
Santa's nerd emoji
yeah that's just how are you right now
Benny just the just the normal nerd
emoji
it's the one he used extra it's extra
hard this one yeah oh God bro this is so
you right now Rhonda Santa said so
just like Chris Hayes dude
cringe
so cringe well the funk music's playing
so
anyway that's about it for us right
that's about it yeah
probably going to end up going to
another picket line now right now no not
right now but maybe tomorrow trying to
rub shoulders with those with those
actors huh yeah I'm just I I every time
I go I bring a script with me and this
time I'll have my head shots as well
like hey guys that's not a bad idea what
no that's actually that's a really good
idea no that's not the reason showing up
to a picket line hey I'm not Union but
uh do you have recent head shots what do
you have recent headshots
but that's a good opportunity I have no
genuine interesting I cannot act for
[__] I am not interested that you're
bringing no
I can't act for [__] I'm not interested
in Hollywood like that at all I'm very
happy with what I'm doing
can you bring some of my scripts
and my headshots no yeah mine too um
yeah just here's my friend Ethan here's
my friend Dan hope you'll consider one
of us for one of your upfront you know
whenever this gets resolved you're going
to need actors friend Neil my friend
Neil
well that's about all I've got to say
about that in the words of Forrest Gump
and uh I'd say we we pretty much solved
it all we never know what you're going
to get we did it all
we did everything right and they
indicted us that's right that still
hasn't left my brain I'm sorry I did
everything
so good yeah well we're back guys hope
you guys enjoyed
um Hassan great to see you welcome back
uh to from the ethno state I know it's
going to be a bummer for you to see
minorities and such walking around L.A
yeah I know it's that's the biggest uh
problem for me but uh hopefully you'll
get to go back to Japan soon where uh
you say that but I am planning on going
back to Japan I want to go back in the
winter I want to go back and go to
Australia and then go to Japan in a
winter
did you go back so soon just because you
loved it so much yeah wow 100 I I was
like I will go to Japan for any any
reason like give me any reason I went I
said I went for the vcts or the Valiant
championship and I didn't even attend
the vcts I was like too busy cutting
bamboo with Samurai swords
sumo wrestling too yeah that Vlog is out
on my second Channel
yeah pretty cool pretty cool stuff well
there it is um
uh thank you guys we'll be back tomorrow
Friday for after dark another great
episode planned of course which is uh
different from today's episode uh
tomorrow's will be good what will you
always say that well I'm just being
honest you always say it like leftovers
episodes are shitty I think about every
episode God damn don't feel bad this was
actually a good episode I actually could
have so as opposed to the other ones
yeah once I had fun oh thank God all
right well thank you guys see you
tomorrow uh thank you son see you next
week and uh thank you everyone for
watching we are all domestic terrorists
oh
foreign